welcome to the intermediate level NLP
tutorial today we're all at PI data NYC
we all know that my name is oddity and
today Eugene and I would be introducing
the concept of language modeling we have
structured our today's talk in five
sections as you can see here we'll be
driving with the intuition behind
language models what does it even mean
to model language that is something so
unstructured and something that can be
very noisy in the second section here
we'd be giving you some glimpse of the
present applications of language models
in the third section we'll be diving
into one of the earlier known language
models the Engram language models the
first session did touch upon engrams and
what they really are as well the first
three sections are expected to take
about 20 to 30 minutes
in the fourth section we'd be diving
actually into an exercise where we'd be
doing hands-on work in the dribbler a
notebook that hopefully you would have
set up by that time there's a small tiny
Twitter challenge in that exercise part
we do have some goodies to give away for
the best tweet and the details of that
tweet would be coming up soon I mean of
course in the fourth session not sooner
than that but in the fourth fifth part
here Eugene would be introducing how the
language models are being used today or
what are the new implementations of
language model algorithms not just the
Engram language models so driving with
the language model in tradition I want
us to understand that it is something
that our mind does very implicitly very
effortlessly and to understand that part
I want us to play along with me for a
little bit
let's make our mind guess what the next
word here would be are there any
candidates
right right all right excellent
so with one word given your mind could
think of like multiple different options
here and all of them might be correct
some of that there might be highly
probable some of them might not be but
let me limit the vocabulary a little bit
let's say that you only have these three
words which one would you pick
models well that's that also in this
case at least becomes quite obvious
because you have all here you're
expecting a blue world there is no other
pre world you pick models what next are
well that's a word it's a perfect they
are indeed let me throw in some more
context knowledge here this is a famous
saying by George box he wrote it in 1979
as far as I know but what do you think
where this is the sentence is going so
what your mind really did here as you
would have already gathered you use the
password to predict the next word among
so many different which could have fit
that particular space so it uses the
probability of the next word using the
context and in the second case here you
were looking at the last two words and
so on and so forth and putting it in a
little bit of a mathematical way you say
that probability of models here in the
first space was greater than seeing
probability of word given all and in the
second one here probability of seeing
are given all and models was more than
the probability of is given all and
morals just because they were plural now
what you just did was essentially learn
a probability distribution over sequence
of words and that
what essentially our language model is
and if your algorithm is good enough to
learn that probability distribution it
can also answer questions like the ones
you just did and with this I'll hand
over to Eugene could be talking about
the present applications Thank You didi
and so now that we've kind of got in a
sense of how language models work well
now dive into some of the applications
of how they're actually used and so
where are like which models used today
the short answer is almost everywhere in
NLP actually so almost all of the
state-of-the-art algorithms nowadays all
have some sort of language model behind
them backing them and so these things
range from things like sentiment
analysis or entity detection and some
that we'll be going into a little bit
deeper in this talk translation and text
generation so to start with autocomplete
you might be familiar with this
application from things like when your
phone tries to guess the next word
you'll be saying we're in search engines
and how it works behind the scenes is
actually very similar to the exercise
that I didi just led us through the
language model here is basically trying
to figure out based on the previous
words that you typed what the next word
you'll be typing are another example of
where a language model plays a pretty
big role is in translation and so to see
how this happens let's say that we want
to translate the French phrase
Lagrangian Rouge a Clifford into English
so the first thing you might want to do
is actually just figure out hey what
English words do each of these French
terms correspond to and so doing a
word-for-word translation
we'll get something like the big dog
bread is Clifford but now that we have
this kind of one the next question won't
be what order should we put these words
in so we put them in alphabetical order
maybe an order like this or
like that yeah and so this is where a
language model becomes really useful so
if you recall the definition that a
language model is a probability
distribution across the sequence of
words I can use a language model to
assign a probability to each of these
candidate sentences I don't believe the
language model would tell us hey the big
red dog is Clifford most probable
sentence of the bus and from there
hopefully it will give the translation
model overall some information that
maybe that particular substance would be
the most likely translation and so here
if we just look at a quick formula for
how a lot of the traditional translation
models have operated you'll see that the
language model plays in here through
this last term where it kind of gives
some indication for hey we got a
candidate English sentences and which
one of these is the most likely
now the last one I want to go into is a
fun example through text generation and
so once you've kind of gotten a model
for how language works you can actually
start using that model to generate
arbitrary text as well and so this is
actually what something exactly what
someone did online and so what this
person did was they actually took a
language model and trained it on a bunch
of recipes and then they asked it hey
spit out a random recipe for me now and
so see yeah kind of makes sense we're
making small sandwiches today where we
got some ingredients some instructions
of course you'll notice that some things
may seem a little bit off like putting
some keys and quarter-inch cubes or a
1-1 inch not really sure what that is
now some researchers in MIT actually
took this one step further they trained
a language model on a bunch of CS papers
and asset to produce a new paper and so
this is actually the paper I produced
and so you see again it kind of makes
sense it has title abstract a lot of
jargon in it and you complete and stuff
like that and apparently this is what
some other people thought - this caper
was actually accepted in conference and
those later redacted when they found out
it was actually generated by machine I
think that kind of speaks for the power
that these language models have there's
a next I'll hand it back to a DD to talk
about a specific language model
algorithm and also in the exercise
section which we started to create
generate text of your own this one
all right so we'll be driving into one
implementation of language models which
is Engram language models and this is
not to drive the motivation of you
creating your own research papers and
summiting but hopefully we'll get a
glimpse into how one of the earliest
known language models were created we
would not be touching any of the neural
network language models we're leaving
that for the third set session here but
let's dive into engrams for for some
time as with any language model Engram
language model is also trying to predict
the probability of a sequence of words
there so going back to our sentence that
we've been working with let's try to
figure out how Engram language models
would work if they're trying to predict
the probability of all models are wrong
taking a step back most of us would
already know what engrams are but just
for the recap here if you have if you
take one word at a time
that's called a unigram by grams you're
taking pairs of words in your sentence
and for the trigrams you're taking three
words at a time and that's called a
trigram so moving forward and ROM
approach we've categorized the Engram
approach into three tricks the first one
here is you can work the joint
probability in two conditional
probabilities so by by that I mean you
start with the joint probability of
seeing all of those words together and
convert it into a conditional
probability equation here by saying that
okay I want to see the probability of
models given all which is what was the
first question asked you then you add
probability of are given all and models
and multiply it with the probability of
wrong given all models are so sense the
probability of each word given all the
words prior to that trick number two
which is essentially a Markov chain
approximation as some of you might
already know you approximate the
so instead of looking at all the words
before that particular word you only
look at some of them and you say that
that's good enough for me to predict the
next word in this example here I'm only
taking the word before the probability
of my given word and because I'm taking
two words at a time for instance morning
given our our given model and not or
everything that existed before this is
known as by Gram language for it taking
two words at a time trick number three
slightly nuanced but in order to capture
the start and the end probabilities you
add start and end tokens so your
equation starts looking something like
this can somebody say why would we want
to do something like that I mean I think
I already answered it but can somebody
explain this to me yeah yeah now you
need you need that so essentially the
start the start and the end token helps
you understand what are the probable
words that a sentence can start with
right the first one here the probability
of all given s and then here the end
token helps you understand where can a
sentence probably end so for instance
the probability of the sentence ending
in R would be lesser than probability of
the sentence and being in wrong so
that's what the end token gives us so
that was trick number 3 combining all of
them together convert the joint
probability which is what the definition
of language models is to conditional
approximate the history instead of
faking everything behind it you take one
word or n words n minus 1 words and then
you add the start and end tokens
combining all of them together you get a
formula that looks like this in this
case we're only doing two words at a
time so by ground language models but
focusing diving a little bit deeper into
one of those terms here what what does
probability of wrong given R comes down
to
that is essentially counting at the end
of the day based on the corpus that
you're learning your language model on
probability of wrong given R would be
approximated by count of our wrong
divided by the number of times that the
word are appeared in your corpus by this
time I have given you every tool
essentially that's needed to learn an
Engram language model and I want you to
give some thought on what happens when
one of those counts goes to zero or is
not present in your language model or in
the corpus that you're learning your
language model on with this I will hand
over to Eugene who would take you
through the exercise all right so now is
everyone's favorite part the exercise of
the Twitter challenge so for this
exercise we're going to be creating our
own program language model and then i'm
using to generate some text of our own
so if you hadn't already time if you
guys are clothed or I just pulled this
github repository and then we'll want to
start off with the notebook titled
language model Victoria and then I'm
also it's kind of take a minute to set
this up for myself as well I will be
around in case somebody's have having
any setup problems please feel free to
ask questions I'll be moving around
and can everyone see this okay I was big
enough all right so why don't we get
started
so the first cell here is just a
containing a lot of useful imports that
we'll be doing so kind of just run it
nothing too crazy going on here two
functions that will just be pretty
useful later on is one to flatten a list
so if you have a list of lists turning
into a 1d array of lists and the other
one here that we also define is one two
pretty print tuples so we'll be working
with a lot of tuples in this notebook
because to store like the buy grams and
trigrams and so just finding a way of
printing it a nice way so we're defining
this function here so to be able to
train a language model kind of like a DD
mentioned the first thing you need is a
corpus of example in this case English
text to kind of let the language model
know hey this is what English looks like
and so the first corpus that we'll be
working with is one called the brown
corpus it's a collection of a lot of
English language texts from about 500
different sources and they've actually
grouped it into 15 different categories
as well and so well can be using an ltk
to actually get this data set and so
they actually provide a really
convenient function to get the sentences
from this data set as well so all you
have to do is call brown dot sense
and it'll actually return an array of
all the sentences in the brown corpus
and so here just printing five example
sentences will see something like
something about the Fulton County grand
jury so maybe like looks like a news
article talking about a court case of
some sort looking at us one single token
I sentence a little bit more well notice
that actually comes in the form of array
of words or tokens and so this is
actually very convenient because for
Ngram language models we need to know
what like a word or token this and so
this form that an otk kind of already
gives it to us kind of alleviates a lot
of the pre-processing that we'll have to
do it we would have to do ourselves and
if you are interested in actually
learning how to build this from scratch
in the appendix Appendix A I believe we
actually have an example where we
download the brand corpus offer URL and
do a lot of this tokenizing and
separation ourselves some things that I
just wanted to know about this
tokenizing as well is one you'll notice
that NLT k decided to remove the
punctuation from the words and I think
especially for angry language models
this was pretty useful because it kind
of you don't treat place period as a
token you actually treat them separately
so whether place is at the end of the
sentence or a middle of the sentence
it's still the same word on the other
thing is just to know that there are
many things that we actually could have
done to pre-process this text more such
as lower casing all the words or
stemming or moving punctuation but just
for the sake of this exercise we'll just
leave it as this from NLT kick
alright so the first step we'll want to
do and kind of the key to building an
Engram language model is knowing how to
count and so we'll warm up with kind of
answering a slightly simpler question
which is hey what are the most common
you know grams that show up in our
corpus and so to do this we'll use a
Python object count encounter and for
those who aren't familiar with it a
counter is kind of like a dictionary
except that has a default value of 0
when the key doesn't exist so
essentially built to count things and it
also has a really convenient most common
function to get the most common elements
from it by the eyes counts and so to do
this here in this little snippet of code
what we're doing is we're first creating
a counter object and then we're
iterating through each word in each
sentence and basically incrementing how
many times you've seen that word and so
I'll go down here we'll see that oh our
data set has 56,000 unique words in it
and a lot of the top words actually make
a lot of sense things like the of and
like very common common English terms
and another thing we can do and I won't
go into this code too much but it's
mostly plotting is we can actually plot
the distribution of these words as well
and this is going from most common to
least common and this plot actually
shows the phenomenon commonly known as
zips law which says that the most common
word show up exponentially more often
that the less common ones and so you can
kind of see that in the shape of this
graph here as well there has a really
long right tail and now just go into a
little bit of a shorter side kind of as
we're exploring this data set I think
important thing to bring up as well as
just the notion of stop words as well so
stop words are often words that people
when they're doing some NLP or sometimes
think aren't as like interesting per se
and though there's no like strict
definition for what a stop word is
people have kind of created their own
lists including n ltk as well and so
here we can see some examples of they
think words like I me myself you know
are quite as interesting and so what we
can do here is actually kind of take
these counts again but take out the stop
words and also punctuation
see some of the more interesting words
that characterize our corpus and so in
this particular example you might see
that a lot of these words actually don't
are two interesting per se as well and I
think that kind of just speaks to how
general of a corpus the brown corpus is
and again we can also take this list and
create another plot as well and what's
interesting here is even after taking
out the stop where it's in punctuation
it's still pretty exponential looking
curve here as well so now that we've
gone through counting unit grams or
words let's move into counting higher
levels of engrams starting with by grams
and so to be able to do this walk she
need to make a slight modification to a
unigram counting code and as a reminder
offer when counting by grams for a
sentence like the red dog is Clifford
will want to the bar grams and that
particular sentence would be the red red
dog dog is is Clifford and Clifford
period and then kind of as a DeeDee
mentioned looking at if we add the
special sentence and message it's begun
tokens we'll also get 2 additional
tokens here and so the COBE have here is
actually largely similar to what we had
before except we do a we actually track
with the previous word as' so that we
can start putting these diagrams
together and so again we're iterating
through each word of every sentence and
that we're incrementing the bigram
counter with the diagram of the previous
word with the current word and then we
update the word to the what the previous
word was and then in addition we'll also
actually be adding a additional diagram
to capture that sentence anything and
then also resetting the previous word to
sentence began once we finished going
through a sentence and so we'll see here
that a lot of the top diagrams are the
top by graham by far is a period with
the sentence end token and that actually
makes a lot of sense because a lot of
sentence will end with the period and
then we'll see things like of the
sentences like to start with though as
well
and so just looking at this code again
you know I think doing this by hand is
just really instructive for knowing you
know how do we count by grams but of
course writing it from scratch each time
we're expanding this to work with
trigrams for grams and so on can be
quite complicated um you'll notice that
there are a lot of corner cases so maybe
if you're off by one you'll just get
some completely wrong answers and so
conveniently as will be a theme
throughout the rest of this notebook and
ltk provides a function to do this for
us it's called the engrams and so what
this function does is it takes the
sentence as an argument and kind of your
end so here with my grams our n is 2 and
then we also tell it to Pat it on the
right and the left with the sentence and
the sentence begun tokens and you kind
of notice the output here again it's
exactly the same all right and now as a
quick exercise I like you maybe I'll
give you like 30 seconds or a minute
just to answer the following question
for what are the most common trigrams in
our data set now and I would recommend
using the NL TK implementation of an
grams rather than writing your
all right now
yeah bringing everyone back I'll also
just go through this exercise really
quickly together so basically yeah I
guess and usually in computer science
just not very good to copy paste code
but for the sake of exercise we're gonna
do that here and basically we can take
the same code that we had before and
just make quick find a replace to just
rename our variable to a trigram counter
and then if we change the argument from
an grams from two to three this will
give us the top trigrams that appear in
our corpus and so looking through this
corpus again we have some you know
pretty familiar candidates so ending a
sentence and beginning a sentence with
the AI both appear as the top two again
but one question that's kind of food for
thought is why don't the top diagram
show up in the top trigrams and so if
you look at the top I grams and notice
that not all of them show up as
candidates for what the top trigrams are
and so does anyone have any ideas for
why this is the case
you need seem to double pad things at
the beginning in the end so the first
word if the last words period that I
mean period end end shows up but so many
teens are the beginning the end of and
like doesn't rank what you include all
the beginnings in the end mm-hmm yeah
that's that's basically it and so as you
kind of noticed like a lot of the
beginning and end tokens show up a lot
here and I think you know it's very
common to see certain punctuation ending
and beginning sentences a lot oh yeah so
when I look at the first one and an end
that makes sense yes but then I would
expect the beginning like the trigram
yeah and that's actually an artifact of
kind of how we tokenized that sounds the
same as the fire safety director in our
building 200 yeah actually oh yeah
so yeah it's a sense we did only one
sentence at a time we didn't give it a
notion that we're chaining the sentences
together so it'll actually Pat it with
to start sentence begin and sentence and
tokens on each side three which was like
start and end tokens there are people
doing only one at a time we were
building a by here because we're doing
trigram language one you want to go from
the start of the word to behind right
and
so it's like padding too on both sides
does double space would it would a
double space get captured in the
background a double space ah that's
interesting yeah so for that question
part of what how I know TK actually
pre-process their text is they I think
they probably use the space as a
tokenizing so they probably split on
space so that an empty space is never a
token here but I imagine depending like
if you actually did want to preserve
that well but it's being captured the
single space oh this is the sentence
begin and since it isn't this token
though okay um so if we would like quad
gram right we'd expect the same probably
like a beard shows up and then one to be
really the most right so you might want
to remove those words it's just like you
could remove the stock and also aside on
Stafford
some of you are having problems
downloading and lt care Stoppers please
bypass that and move forward and assume
that you cannot get rid of stop board
for now that's a side effect of NRT game
download library but coming back to your
question sir
if you remove your moment yeah we can
actually risk of lifetime where you can
try that real quick by just removing the
padding as well and seeing what comes
out yes exactly well see for the
language model yeah so actually yeah
this is kind of cool you'll see like the
United States is pretty common of course
some punctuation as well cool so moving
forward once we have the ability to
count these angry um's we can actually
start creating probability distributions
from them too and so kind of just
focusing on the bigram example where
we're gonna be creating a bigram
language model we can approximate the
probability for a word given that it's
context by just looking at the previous
word and kind of as a DD mentioned
earlier you can figure out what this
probability is by taking the counts so
here we're basically taking the count of
how many times the diagram shows up and
dividing it by the count of how many
times the context where it shows up
showed up in this approximation for the
probability is actually also known as
the maximum likelihood estimator for
those that are familiar with that
concept and so one slight nuance here is
actually to be able to do this well
we're need to store a bigram slightly
differently so instead of each count
counting each diagram directly we're
actually going to create a map to map
each context to the number of times the
word follows that context and so to do
this we're creating a dictionary here
called a bigram context counter and then
like before where for each sentence were
going through each of the engrams the
diagrams in this case and then if that
context were so the first word there
doesn't
in our dictionary we're gonna create
just a new counter object to start
storing how many times that where it has
appeared and then we're just gonna
increment it like before and so to kind
of start motivating why we're storing it
this way with this storage mechanism we
can easily start answering some more
interesting questions such as what are
the most common words that start a
sentence and so can anyone tell me what
we should put in this little to do block
exactly so we insert the sentence begin
token here this will give us the most
common words that have been used to
start a sentence and so you see where
it's that we kind of expect like the key
and so on and just going back to this
equation here we can actually start you
use these counts to derive a probability
distribution and so here's the function
called get word probabilities that kind
of takes in that context counter and
then what it does first is it computes
the total counts by just adding all of
the counts and that gives us the
denominator here and then what it does
is it creates a dictionary mapping each
word to its probability by dividing the
count of the bigram over the total
counts in here and so kind of running
this will basically see something very
similar except now all the words the
counts have been converted into
probabilities and so next since this
data structure is actually quite
important well I'll give you maybe
another minute or two just to go through
some of the next exercises to see how
you can use the data structure to answer
some some other questions
one of the ones that did it for that's
for the blue sky yeah there's this light
reorder
yep so bringing it back yeah just doing
it here overall you can see that by
putting the words that you're looking
for into these blanks you can get like
hey these are the most common words that
come after the word blue or this is so
blue seems to 97 times in our corpus and
blue sky appeared four times and so I
guess there are two ways of kind of
deriving the probability that sky comes
after the word blue one is just taking
the word number four and dividing it by
97 here or as you can see we can also
again just take advantage of that
function we wrote to get a map of all
the probabilities and so here
sky comes after the word blue about 4%
of the time and so actually going
through this whole exercise what we've
essentially created now is our very own
diagram language model and so to make
that clear we're actually just gonna
rename the variable really quickly as
well and we're just gonna suffix it with
the phrase manual just to kind of
indicate that this is one that we
constructed by hand and just quick
clarification here too even though the
object is a counter and a language model
is really in the end assigning
probabilities to different sequences you
can use as we've seen you can use these
counts to derive those probabilities and
so this data structure that we have here
is a core of on what we need and so
we're calling that the goal of the
language model again is to be able to
assign probabilities to a sequence of
words or show how we can do that with
the language model that we just created
and so here let's say that we wanted to
see the probability of seeing the
sentence the blue sky is beautiful what
we could do to get that is first getting
all the diagrams from this sentence
again using the NLT kay anagrams
function and then basically we kind of
start a rolling probability with one and
we update basically take the product of
all of these different conditional
probabilities together by using the get
word probabilities function similar to
what we
appeared and so doing that we actually
get that the probability of seeing the
blue skies beautiful is some very very
small number here and so yeah one thing
way that one thing one trick that people
use often to deal with help deal with
these very small numbers is also to take
the lock and so now you can see that oh
the law of probability of the blue skies
beautiful is negative twenty nine point
one and if you're familiar with as well
to avoid the floating point error one
thing that you can do when you're
computing the if you wanted to compute
the log probability directly is to
actually take the sum of the log
probabilities because it essentially
multiplies all of the insights together
and so now that we've kind of gone
through the exercise of implementing a
language model from scratch let's uh
let's see how we can do it with n LT K
and so with the NLT case implementation
there is a little bit of you know a
little bit of time just to understand
kind of what their ap eyes look like and
how they accept their training data and
so here they the analytic a call to
their implementation the M le which is a
short for again maximum likelihood
estimator so the constructor takes in an
argument end that specifies what the
Engram length you want to use is and as
you'll note here we actually haven't
trained anything yet
so the vocabulary size is still zero now
to add some data into the N l TK
language model will actually get have to
give it in a very particular form that
they actually have a function called
padded every grand pipeline that
provides it and so this function returns
basically two objects one is the what we
call train text is a list of all of the
in this case you know grams and by grams
that came from our corpus and the second
argument is essentially the set of
vocabulary that is derived from our
corpus as well
and then calling the fit function it
basically uses these these diagrams and
you know grams as well as a vocabulary
to basically do what we did above to
create the language model and so once
we've trained the language model well I
can see that oh it's about fifty six
thousand words in total and so with this
language model we can again answer some
of the questions that we saw before and
so one thing here on one neat trick as
well is if you want to know what
functions given an object had as you can
use the dere function that will actually
print out all of the methods that a
Python object has and so a lot of these
start with the double underscores which
are just kind of like built-in functions
but here you'll see the ones that
they've defined themselves as well
including useful ones that count its
contacts counts entropy fit and so on
and some of these will find pretty
useful so the first one we'll use here
is just the counts and so running this
we again can answer hey what are the
most common words that come after blue
and yeah just one small nuance here is
that though you'll notice that the way
we specified blue in this tuple is kind
of weird we have the first thing in the
tuple is the string blue and the second
is actually just empty and this is more
of an artifact of how Python has to find
their tuples or basically if we get rid
of this coma it'll actually interpret it
as a literal string I believe in this
accounts object and so having that comma
there somehow explicitly tells it that
oh this is actually a tuple so we'll
want to get the context and again we can
also compute probabilities like before
and so they provide a very convenient
function called score that basically
converts so if you wanted to see what is
a probability of that sky comes after
the context blue and again doing a
really similar piece of code from above
except just replacing the probability
down here with the I know TK score
function we can again compute the
probability that the sentence the blue
sky is beautiful and here we'll notice
that it's actually exactly the same as
the
we did about all right so now that we've
gone through how we can create these
language models we'll actually use it in
an application of generating different
sentences like the examples that we
presented before and again like before
what we're gonna do is actually we're
gonna start off by implementing this
manually again just to get a sense for
how it works and then we'll show how you
can do it with NLT kay so to start we're
going to Judy wrote something called a
greedy method and so you can imagine
that one way you could try to generate
these sentences to start with the
sentence begin token and then ask your
language model what is the most common
word to show up after sentence began and
then just keep doing the picking the
most likely word one after the other
until you get to a sentence I'm token
and so we're gonna call this the greedy
method here and this is what it produces
so can anyone kind of volunteer for why
they think this happened or what do you
think is wrong with this approach yep
yeah so it's basically deterministic and
in this case it actually ran itself into
a loop as well so like and the same time
and the same time seems to just keep
looping over and over on itself and so
to make this a little bit better
we're actually going to use a little bit
of randomization and so the method here
is pretty similar to before except now
we can repeatedly compute the
probability of a word given its context
and then select a word random from that
distribution I'm sorry there's a slight
mistake here this should be a since
we're doing a bigram language model just
a single word context and then we can
repeat that until we get the sentence ID
token and just going into the code a
little bit here the get random next word
is pretty integral to this function and
so what it does is it gets the again the
word counts from the object that we
created before and gets a set of
probabilities as well as the vocabulary
and then using the function and P dot
random choice from numpy
you can give it the vocabulary that you
want it to select a random element from
and you can weight each element by the
probability so it basically gives you a
random word based on the probability
distribution and so using this we can
actually start generating random
sentences and some notes on this
arguments so here again it's just the
language model that we created and then
the text seed is just an option if you
wanted the sentence to start with a
particular word like or I don't really
like bananas or something like that and
then you can also give it a random seed
as well so this is kind of just to
control the random number generator if
you want to determine produce
deterministic results and so yeah
through this little bit of code here
we're basically starting with the
context of the sentence begin and then
if we do have a text seed we kind of
replace it with that and then we just
iterate until we get to the sentence on
token and just to run through a few
examples here so for the first one we
seeded it with the word thaw and this so
says the Odyssey is boss I guess they
really like the Odyssey and here just
seating it with nothing and stuff
started the word with like someone
laughs with its associated I don't know
textile machinery and some boats a
bigram
language model and again just we can
play with this some more so like we can
try changing the random seed as well
just seeing kind of what sentences it
produces yeah it has a lot of parole of
industries now so you notice that it
like kind of almost makes sense but like
definitely not quite there and actually
if we put in our favorite programming
language as well you actually notice
that it gives an error so it says hey
this ain't great model has never seen
the word Python start a sentence before
and so this kind of ties in a little bit
into the example that a didi was
mentioning about before where if our
model has never seen a particular
diagram before or in this case the word
Python starting a sentence it just won't
know what to do and so there are some
ways of getting around this
the technique called smoothie and so I
won't go into it here but well there's
an appendix as well that goes into that
if you're interested finally to finish
just showing a quick example of how and
you can do it with an LT K as well and
it's actually really neat so I know TK
again has a function that takes in a
taxied in a random seed as well I mean
you just have to call the function
generate and you can tell it how many
tokens you want to generate as well so
we'll just do 50 to be safe and then
this slight for loop here again is just
to basically iterate all of the
generated over all of the generated
tokens until we get to a sentence n
token just so that the substance that
printed that's printed out looks pretty
it's like here yeah I guess another
example that it produced yeah a standard
yeah so maybe it could be quite deep as
well sometimes all right and so now
we're done with this notebook and so if
you could open up fun and language
models notebook so I actually won't be
going through this notebook with you but
maybe I'll probably give like five to
ten minutes or so and then yeah so
basically this notebook will kind of go
through the effect of changing the
Engram length how it affects the
sentences you generate as well as
changing the data set and then of course
the exciting part is our Twitter
challenge and I think I'll let a DeeDee
kind of do that so we are providing you
a framework a skeleton of things that
you can do to play with different energy
K corpus opera it's not just that's the
link that you can click to play around
with different
yep so it actually contains a list of
all the corpora that NLT he already has
included and so includes things like a
lot of classic literature I think it
also has like online dating profiles too
so if you want to make your own for
those it's a hook and then once you pick
what senses you're interested in and the
Engram length that you want to
experiment with you would be able to
create your own language morning and
then generate as well
so essentially whatever we went is
concise within these three Styles here
all know to run these Fiza you would
need the top two cells of this notebook
which will help you import all the
required libraries as well as run some
of the credit fiying
functions that you might need yeah and
please make sure that you are tagging
your tweet okay oh you're tweeting the
sentence that comes out of your language
for that that's the ask essentially and
keep trying until you get something that
you're happy with Sigma and this is the
email is right here doing that and then
new generation we've been doing all
along but now you keep doing it from
scratch using it yeah and for a prizes
will be giving away these two sigma and
Nalgene bottles with a custom 3d printed
keychain inside and yeah these you can't
get from the swag table so uh
batch of things
this is the
[Music]
and
but moving forward we have three main
takeaways from this exercise and
something that I was just talking about
number one that a language model is
essentially all about counting for the
formula that you're seeing here which we
generated using the three tricks all of
these parts come down to doing these
counts from the corpus that you sum it
into the language model but the question
was what happens when your model has not
seen the word before and you're trying
to ask what is the probability of seeing
all models are gobbledygook
when that word never really existed
there that is where the concept that
Eugene touched upon called
smoothing comes into picture here I'm
introducing just one way of smoothing
which is laplacian Locka smoothing plus
one you can choose to do plus 1 or plus
n or for the matter even fractional
counts can be added but what smoothing
essentially does is that it takes the
counts of the known and unknown words
here a gobbledygook is at the bottom and
adds one to it
and as such what it ends up doing is it
assigned some of the probability mass
from known words to unknown words as
well because here although the problem
although the chances of seeing all more
than the robbery cook is very very small
it should not be 0
it makes grammatical sense so smoothing
here which is as I mentioned one of the
ways of handling smoothing is class 1
smoothing applies some count here and
assigns the probability mass to
gobbledygook as well number 2 and
matters and there's a trade-off
essentially if you keep n quite small
you're making your language model quite
generalizable if you make it larger if
you have let's say if you're picking
five words at a time they start becoming
more specific to the koch's so let me
throw in some examples here for instance
when you have a unigram language model
it's essentially just throwing up one
random word at a time in that it looks
like English because it was learned on
English but the sentence on a whole is
not making much sense here now on the
same corpus when you increase your n to
2 that sentence is looking much better
but still not making a lot of sense
trigram is when it actually starts
throwing out some nice-looking sentences
here that can anybody guess where what
corpus this is Shakespeare absolutely oh
sweet prince foul stuff shall die
awesome and then if you train a
foreground model here do you think that
this is the best is that the one that we
want to go ahead with and use it in our
following pipeline maybe not because now
what's happening is it's probably
picking sentences as it is from the
corpus and throwing throwing back at us
take away number three the corpus
matters as well so here what you're
seeing is comparison of trigram language
model of Shakespeare versus Wall Street
Journal and although the N is constant
in this example the sentence it is
throwing out for Wall Street Journal is
looking like a news article and if you
look if you focus on the underlying part
here it's trying to say that okay rape
rates of interest are soaring in Mexico
before that it's also trying to say
ninety nine point six billion dollars
it's trying to throw in some numbers and
making sense doing that with Shakespeare
again this was the previous example just
here for the comparison takeaway number
three is essentially that corpus matters
what what you learn your language model
on matters now yes you have learned your
language model and you have n to choose
from you have the corpus to choose from
how do you evaluate a language model is
good and that really depends on how do
you define what best is for your
application
researchers have divided the evaluation
of language models into two categories
intrinsic evaluation and extrinsic
evaluation in intrinsic evaluation what
ends up happening is let's say that you
had two language models here
Shakespearean and Wall Street Journal
those are the probability distribution
you use these language models to predict
what is the probability of us onion
unseen sentence by that language model
so all models are wrong let's say that
this was a sentence that both of these
language models had never seen before
and we pass it through this framework
and I'll be coming to that later on but
essentially you pass it through this
framework and see which of the two
models is doing better now going back to
what this framework is I am trying to
see which which of these two models has
a higher probability of seeing all
models are wrong and perplexity here is
nothing but probability normalized over
the number of words and
as the name suggests a higher proflex
city is saying that oh I'm quite
perplexed looking at this sentence and
I'm not as likely to predict that this
sentence is coming from from the corpus
that I was trained on so perplexity of
Shakespeare would be something around
fifty one hundred this is for demo
purpose only and perplexity of Wall
Street Journal maybe because it has seen
exact same sequence of words in its
corpus before perplexity would be
smaller coming to the extrinsic
evaluation that is also a method of
evaluating language models but instead
of using the perplexity measure or the
probability measure you pass your
language model through an extrinsic task
and that extrinsic task can be anything
sentiment analysis sentence completion
may be checking for Spelling's and then
you see which of the two models is doing
what we expected to do and for here
Shakespeare my a that I don't know what
to do with the sentence and Wall Street
Journal because it has seen wrong in
negative connotations might give it a
negative sentiment there so coming to
the constraints of language models as
some of you might have already gathered
what's going on here language models
cannot work in long-range dependencies
which by the by the definition of
language is present in any sentence for
instance here all models are wrong but
some are useful models here existed that
at the beginning of the sentence and
some which also refers to the those same
models was at the end of the sentence
and to capture that dependency you would
have to increase your n to five and once
you increase your n to five you're now
like over learning or overfitting to
your corpus that you had submitted
the second constraint here that I want
all of us to take away is the number of
parameters here increases exponentially
as you increase your end as well so the
number of unicron's in shakespeare model
we checked was around 9000 the total
possible by grams would be about 80
million and that number as you're seeing
exponentially grows as you increase your
engrams so the number of parameters that
you'll have to learn to create a
language model would be quite high as
well as you increase your n all right
and with this I'll hand over to Eugene
for the present state of language models
this was Engram language models all
right I was just looking through some of
the submissions and I have to say
they're pretty good I'm very excited to
share some of them for that I just want
to give a quick share on kind of the
models be talking about two things
networks as well as some ethics as well
so start as early as 2002 some people
started have started exploring using
neural networks to Train off language
models and this approach has actually
been proven to be really useful and
almost all the state of the art language
models being produced today are neural
network based including things like Elmo
and ferd and one really powerful thing
about these little network based
language models is that they create a
byproduct of embedded and these
embeddings have proved to be very useful
in kind of just general using deep
learning with NLP in general and so how
these embeddings work is that you give
it a word like let's say the or Python
and it takes that word and embeds it or
converts it into let's say a 300
dimensional vector and with this vector
people have found that they can actually
take the output of this vector and put
it in tape use it as input into the down
stream like deep learning neural
networks and they found that you could
use it for things like sentiment
analysis classification and so on I
think what's really powerful about this
approach is
the vectors that come out already have
some sense of like what the words need
and so taking a numeric representation
of words and feeding into neural network
applications have been proven to be
really useful and so this is actually a
very common pattern that you'll find
nowadays with deep learning and NLP
another quick thing is just on the
ethical concerns around I think
developing these models and I think
touch upon it in the earlier session as
well so here's an example of where open
AI they created this pretty powerful
language model called GPT - but they
actually decided not to release the
model for the public because they're
afraid it'd be used for like deceptive
biased or abusive applications and just
to dive into this a little bit more on
the idea bias there's actually been some
research recently done to show that
there is actually quite a bit of bias in
these language models and embeddings
people found that they contain like in
this example a lot of gendered rice and
it's often because that these models are
trained on text that we humans produce
and so they learned the same biases that
are present in our news or our emails
and things like that and so as language
models and kind of these sophisticated
techniques get used more and more for
things like resume screens or search
engines they can have really real
repercussions for people and so it's
kind of really important to think about
this particular facet of our models as
well so with that we'll bring it back to
the Twitter challenge and hopefully
announce some winners
definitely have not gone through all of
them gave us some time also let's bring
up the submission slide so that phones
fight extradition
what's that corpus gasps there's no few
hours were to have engaged her to
[Laughter]
from every section of our country so
very I think my guess is from a actually
it does anyone know my inaugural
addresses all right I think still has
some work coming in there was one are we
going to Las Vegas or Atlantic City I am
pretty sure that's not coming from a
computer well there's a water bottle
with a keychain in it a 3d printed one
it's not soluble please don't drink it
with your water commute this
[Laughter]
[Music]
please know that we took like two
minutes to decide it has really gone
through all of your submissions oh sorry
yes it's kind of like apples apples that
you know that game
try to
the first one the third place goes to
[Applause]
second place we picked the phone related
one I need to have a best-selling phone
from t-mobile
[Applause]
first place we really like this is
probably pirate related this says if the
company controls the chest they control
the sea we're not providing any
investment advice today happy to take
any questions that hopefully you you
learned something you had some fun
this nights are going to be available on
those website
yes
- excellent I personally am NOT I am
saying because I'm pretty sure there is
treasure out there any other questions
that we can so I'm not like super
familiar with Spacey but I think there
are a lot of like nuance differences
between though but yeah I think I'd be
happy to chat with you after about that
yeah [ __ ] and grandmother's is very Fox
very good bye girl
I think I'm taking anything good here in
just because like Google reviews there
and grunge week that were doing pretty
well but this is honestly do not know
what's in the market to be honest it's
more about neural network language
models now no yes yeah and engrams here
we'll just to give you a favor of like
what language models we are doing and
drugs used to be like long time ago way
of generating yeah I think it depends a
lot on your application as well so kind
of like if you wanted to assign
probabilities to sentences diagram
language models are definitely more
generalizable than let's say for gram or
five gram the same time if you were
generating sentences like maybe try
Gomer for gram would give you more
reasonable ones
I think pi dedos I think will be asking
us for the slides and posting them
somewhere so but yeah so hopefully
that'll be somewhere but the notebooks
of course will be on the questions there
are no more questions thank you for all
coming and we'll be here if you want any
if you have any further questions
[Applause]